says big says huh
is this going is it it looks like it's
about to
now it's going now we're going we're
like we're getting places in line how's
it going people you know the drill tell
us if you can hear us
if you can hear us you just gotta tell
us i got sound waves kicking back on the
tuesday in the chat
yo yo yo how's it going erica how's it
going tm agoraphobic fanboy
thwipster card of love let's get our
quick hellos in here today
jordan metz tnn gardner tm yeah
mr vajoo dave's
james bradley hey bradley
i see you bradley i said matthew mr
vaahu i think we get all eric horseman
happy belated birthday eric horseman
carter lovejoy um
dark side matters oh man this is gonna
be a fun stream today
you know how i know it's gonna be fun
how you know how i know it's gonna be
fun how's that
because um what's what's your title
other than not sleeping lately
oh yeah remember and then john chose
this topic today and i was like
great topic let's do it and then uh
before we went live i was like oh [ __ ]
i haven't prepared a single answer
all right one answer in mind of what to
remake
great because i'm about to put you on
the spot damn there's so much here
that i think we should remake this is
gonna be a relaxing one today let's see
how
let's see how our feelings go yeah with
everything but yeah today's theme
remakes and reboots we'd actually like
to see what's up thwipster
uh i haven't seen euphoria mark leach in
the chat
hey orlando so many wonderful familiar
names and some new names
hello new names alistair campbell yeah
ooh
uh we are i am excited for dune oh and i
appreciate those who already
uh submitted to the super chat we also
got stream labs we want to end this at a
sharp
5 30 p.m seven o'clock
p.m today we're gonna we're gonna
knock it off let's just have some fun
let's kick this stream off
john since you came up with today's
topic
question to you i got a question what's
that what's that what's that
hey john hey john hey what
show us how you get down no way
okay oh wn and that's the way you get it
down
what is a movie you would like
to judas that was one answer that came
to mind i see your name in the
chat um yeah what is one movie
or show i guess that you would like to
see
rebooted or remade humphrey
john allen kick us away see here's the
thing is right now in this moment i'm
conflicted only because we have received
a super chat for one movie that i
have for years been thinking like this
movie
totally deserves it so okay so i think i
i
will uh hold off for a moment on that
one but to go to the tv
end uh i think there are a lot of shows
that have been canceled way too soon
sure and uh freaks and geeks was one
that i would love to see like rebooted
in a way where you know it's like that
was all about coming of age and stuff
like that and so like to see where those
characters might have ended up i think
could have been cool
um there's also a film uh this is just a
personal one
to uh go with an alternative there's a
film that toby hooper made in the
80s i want to say called fun house which
is you know like a
it's a demented carnival kind of movie
and it's all right like it's a schlocky
you know campy flick but it's kind of
like the crazies where
you know there's the idea is there and
there are some effective sequences
however with a greater budget
and more resources etc you know this
could have been dynamite
and that's a movie i i would like to and
it's you know it's like it's not a
beloved movie it's like a cult classic
or something so
wow that would be fun i think you have
some great pics
thanks okay and i've seen a lot of you
guys in the chat who are putting down
some awesome picks
already need for speed i'm seeing a
franchise needs reboot a lot of great
a lot of great picks but i got a i got
one that i
i once prepped for a movie fight
argument
on on the screen junkies movie fight
show
and um we didn't end up having the
question so i'm just gonna
pull it over to here today for you guys
it's one that will be met with backlash
this is real rambo
first blood they should reboot
first blood um i'm not a fan of where
the franchise has really gone
and also um the
the book it's the movie the first blood
is based on a book
and on that book it's com the movie
plays out
very different and this became like a
weird schlocky action franchise that
turned into a very grim
trying to go for realistic brutality
franchise
and the first the first blood the book
and the movie itself the the actual cut
of sylvester stallone's first blood
that was like a three-hour cut
originally before it became like 80 to
90 minutes
and that's because there is so much
more explored that's a real character
study
dealing with ptsd so that's in there and
the sylvester stallone one
but there's no way that if you adapted a
faithful adaptation of first blood
that you would turn into the franchise
that it become there's just no way it's
possible
so i would actually like to see a very
grounded realistic take
rebooting first blood starring michael b
jordan
or sean krasinski or something i don't
know there you go
let's go with that one but to name off a
couple of i mean we're getting some cool
uh ones in the chat but
we see some people who have had super
chats we don't want to last time we live
streamed we got to
three hours behind on the super chat so
i want to make sure
exactly see dave's film total in the in
the live stream i didn't want to say it
but that is what happens in the book
hence it's a very different thing right
yeah
yeah yeah yeah so we got some super
chats we don't want to fall three hours
behind today so
john let's pull up some of the super
chats here no
problem all right so on this left-hand
side
rambo versus rambo double hit all right
oh god we got the agoraphobic
fanboy first and foremost oh we can
never
deploy from the chat agoraphobic fanboy
um one who i'll never want to annoy
wait till i'm done with my poem that's
what we're doing today instead of
freestyling
it's the same gimmick i'll grab my
bottle opener really quick
and you you you do your your spoken word
and uh
agoraphobic fanboy can be allergic to
soy
but yeah you know what he's a man who i
would never want to destroy what did you
say today he said a soft
reboot of mars attacks with tim burton
at the helm again
now having el uh slightly edgier darker
elements or more comedic
sensibilities hmm you know i
i just re-watched this a few weeks ago
can you see it being remade
can you see it being remade jon take it
away you know
what i mean i don't want to be contrary
right off the bat
i i think a reboot if we if we if we
brought it back
i would be down for that just a solid
straight up remake i don't think i would
want just because
i think that movie does ride a special
and unique line that
it pretty much nails for me so i don't
feel like it missed anything
although i do think that yeah if you
wanted to expand it i would be a little
bit like
worried at this point but i would be
down for that because i
i actually that's one of my favorite
underrated burtons
yeah you know i think you could do mars
attacks again but i would probably put
it in a slightly different era not too
far away from
i mean it's it's in it took place at the
time it came out it was a modern time
but the style was from like uh
40s 50s like it was honoring that so
uh i would actually just put it in the
era is what i would do
oh if i were to remake it that's fun see
the producer in greg is coming out today
rambo goes to hollywood i see you in the
chat
dude it's all rambo now
one highlander and a lot of rambos and
then uh thank you to everyone who's
contributed to the super chat
so far um verdugo silver here we go
water oh wait verdugo silver don't
pilfer from verdugo silver
otherwise he'll be on a hill for days
plotting his revenge the various ways
in which he might clap back at you so
you attack at you you follow your words
and you let that go into different
rhymes
i try to just go like only rhyming
verdugo or only arriving
silver and that's that so i judge you
when you d
when you don't do that and then i'm like
but maybe john's method is much more
realistic
it's just two different schools of
rivalry that's all
what did he say verdugo silver's water
world had a lot of potential but just
wasn't done very well i'd love to see
that same premise redone and i
agree i uh wholeheartedly agree with
that statement
water world should absolutely be remade
yeah exactly like
this question is you know comes up
periodically and and every time it is
the one that shines out in my mind of
like
that's a good answer because you know
like it's it's water man max so we
already know that the premise kind of
works
yeah uh but yeah like just to reimagine
that movie and and
hit where the movie missed yeah would be
pretty awesome to behold if they could
do it
i think if you just got rid of the one
element
of kevin and now there's a lot of things
wrong with that movie but
what i what i think it could really help
ground it is if you don't have your main
character be half human half fish man or
whatever
oh yeah i don't think i don't think you
need that i think just real
really living in like a bleak dystopian
that has like cool action yeah mad max
fury robot on water
this is what i'm trying to get out of
here and then maybe at the end
you can hint at half fish hybrid people
if you want to
seeing some people joining the chat if
you're here hit that like button we got
ties in the chat megan
ryan hung low c wood this person who
just said vodka whose name i can't
pronounce lucas
small bill's a good good one i saw a
couple of shouts out to smallville and i
feel like
that could be an interesting one chase
gardner
my friend chase i can always make the
case
that in my mind you will never be erased
for you keep our comments
and our live streams up on a good pace
do i dare rhyme the word gardener
it's harder it's hard a hardener
as i work as a farmer good we're good
thank you chase for your contribution
today farmer
farmer um aren't they working on this uh
percy jackson
movie series reboot i thought they're
working on it or they're working on at
least a tv series reboot
i think you should make it a tv series
that seems to be going really well
because otherwise i feel like there's
some movies that are still getting
locked into that you're not lord of the
rings you're not harry potter stop
but i feel like on reboot aragon i feel
like on uh
tv they can really make it their own and
not really get that comparison
was there a golden compass show that no
one saw or am i just totally making that
up
no i think people it's his dark
materials isn't it that's what it is
yeah it's it's on it's getting a second
season or it has a second yeah i just
got a trailer right you know
at least yeah it wasn't necessarily like
the the
swept everyone up by storm that i think
people thought it might be
yeah see tm says they're doing a tv
series for percy jackson
okay i mean i think they should remake
joker
oh yeah do it it should be the new star
taxi driver who wants to just be a
stand-up comedian
oh wait okay where's my pen for the
random great ones that pop up in the
chat then i'm going to act like they're
my own
all righty here you go g thanks john you
guys keep
saying random ones in the chat because
i'm looking and i'm gonna scroll down to
uh
sarah campbell here in the super chats
from canada how's it going
sarah campbell let me ramble for a
second about sarah campbell let me get
lost in the brambles while i
uh cram a hole again
while i gamble with my luck right now
uh like campbell's chicken noodles yeah
yeah there you go i'm gonna lay down a
doodle after i read your comment i'd
like to see a reboot of doom
ah good call not that carl urban wasn't
a feast for these
good call but i feel like he could do
something cool now
oh you just opened up the door for a
whole bunch of movies i can now take as
my own to say should be rebooted
i just gotta think of a gazillion video
game movies and then i got it if movie
fights ever comes back we're mining from
here i mean if you did a really faith
like
tonally faithful version of doom
where you're just in the mania of gore
and hell and it's fast paced and just
crazy visceral i would
love that i think that would be great
actually i
i don't think he would want me to say
this i have a friend
who is working on a doom
series idea and he has some potential
i'll just say
what he's told me sounds really cool but
at terms of cool of a movie remake
oh that would work you could get the
rock in it you get carl
urban in it um david
just tall weezer around each other
maybe honestly maybe or else he's in the
sequel yeah i don't remember
i don't remember um i i wanted to call
sarah thank you
one day out of morbid curiosity i went
online and rewatched uh just the one
sequence of doom that's in first person
and uh now i feel like yeah if you
rebooted a doom movie and get the
director of hardcore henry hell yeah
i love that one-shot doom sequence the
pov sequence
in that doom movie out of context yeah
it's one of those scenes
when i'm not watching it in the actual
movie i think that that's a really
cool scene yeah when i'm watching the
actual movie i'm like why does this not
work for me
um thank you sarah campbell reboot
prometheus
oh oh oh my god all right look we're
going to take one more super chat then i
want to go to the action and oh i see
some people contributing our stream laps
thank you
we'll go to you guys too in a little bit
but um i'm
uh we'll take bradley's and then i want
to go to the chat and read off some
some quick hitters that i saw bradley
bledsoe
the man who's obsessed with joker oh
uh bradley bledsoe don't you know
that when i find my flow bradley bledsoe
i just let my mind
go i go on the boat with you when i row
yo
and then you smack my ass like i'm your
ho yo
bradley dance yeah what do you got we
don't
douci dough yo
we'll call that rebooting as well um
okay bradley hey guys i'd like to see a
scooby doo reboot in the style of
riverdale i like it
i think it would be interesting take
party on dudes
what can you do that you'd have to get
rid of scoob
um how can you do that with i could see
that with the gang but you can't do it
with scooby there
well i mean maybe more like sabrina
exactly exactly because of the cat it
works
it would be a much more difficult effect
to pull off
but uh i actually would be super down
for that like like as an
alternate take i would much prefer that
to the you know animated let's just make
it a superhero movie
oh my god and then you could make shaggy
like latino and then you could
make like uh uh earth nester who's the
other one
uh fred fred he could be transgender
and then you could have um
velma damn names oddly enough
velma will be the only one who is saying
he keeps this hetero
yeah but then daphne is going to be like
a lesbian then you make
a [ __ ] scoob like pansexual it would
be
great yeah yeah uh yeah i i actually um
i could see it you should get like a
really
raggedy scoob i think would be cool too
yeah like a fairy like a worn out
like he's or he never wanted to be a dog
yeah yeah and he wants to change
he's yeah really bad flashbacks from
being in the pound
all right guys let's see uh thank you
guys for the super chats and contain
those in a minute
somebody called it out in the chat but
somebody said uh do uh
evil dead four and that made me think of
i would love actually if they rebooted
the
the reboot yes if they rebooted the mia
story
i would love to go back to that
personally okay so some ones that i saw
in the chat that i want to read off
that is not on this pad where'd it go
all right
oh god maybe i thought i wrote it down
but i didn't buffy
um getting a reboot i think could be
cool
yeah with joss whedon with josh sweden
behind it get zack snyder's buffy
street fighter i thought they had a tv
series
at one point no they just made that
street fighter legend of chun li movie
but they didn't they have like a uh
there was a there's these the guys who
made like a short film on youtube that
captured
street fighter live action with ken and
ryu fighting in the woods
yeah yeah legacy i think was called yeah
that was dope
that was really cool and i i feel like
you could make a a solid street fighter
movie
um resident evil my god
remake residents also mentioned in the
chat and i
to me i think what would be the the best
way
visually to redo resident evil is
if you capture it like how the first
couple games are captured in the
direction where you like walk into other
shots
that's always i love the way that the
direction is in the game
because uh that scares the crap out of
me when i play it because it's like
you just walk into another another shot
and then you're like oh my god there's a
guy coming after me
and you can't see it until you walk into
the other shot yeah
i've always thought that would be cool
and i don't know about a punisher reboot
right now
weirdly today so uh i was thinking about
that uh
today of um i wonder if they would at
least try because it seems like they're
getting rid of all the marvel netflix
characters
and like or recasting them i wonder if
they'll at least
try to get john bernthal back to stay
because i'm like how many punishers can
you get
he has so many punishers yeah he is and
he knocked it out of the park
he is like yeah one of those guys who
has risen to being definitive
yeah yeah i don't think anybody would
throw a fit if thomas jane
or ray stevenson weren't considered for
that but john berthold is like owns that
character now
and i saw spy kids here in the chat i
think i want
a modern day reboot of spy kids would
totally work especially since
he seems very down to reboot his stuff
rob rodriguez i mean
yeah he had a career off of it doesn't
he yeah yeah i would actually that was
one of the ones i was uh thinking about
is uh i remember seeing that as a kid
and like just the thought of you know i
don't know if i want to have a kid but
if i
did i would want to be able to share a
spy kids reboot
yeah man or just the original spy kid
who said the thing again
who said that no we've learned from that
mistake
um oh you know someone else in the chat
mentioned static shock before live
action
do it dude rode around on a trash can
lid
it was the coolest thing in the world
yeah i did too i thought it was really
cool that and freakazoid
and they are working on a highlander
remake i've seen a lot of that in the
chat too yeah yeah they are
uh yeah they should give in humans
another shot i agree with you ryan
johnson
ryan johnson in the chat um buffy
is getting rebooted really hillary b or
is that can we verify this no don't do
that a live action how to train your
dragon damn that'd be crazy
yeah happy crazy chase
you know what i want to do is i i want
to reboot repo the genetic opera but
with the cast of repo men
yeah and then you know see jude law and
force whitaker sing all those songs
michael you know we all wanted a batman
beyond live action we're already hoping
for that
truthful truth that oh god i feel like
there's
one like what's a movie that had a lot
of potential
i feel like gemini man gemini yeah
you could do that yeah kanye west
oh my god that would be better that
would work better
um yeah i know there's something in
there there's
there's been movies that we've seen
where i'm like so much potential and
yeah
proper remake they could have really
nailed this justice league
justice league release the snyder the
snyder cuts
it'll come to us don't worry i really
want a josh train cut
yeah that would be cool all right guys
well i think we're watching good let's
let's we can't fall too behind today we
can
fall too behind today all right we gotta
make sure we're doing this properly
today
all right kyle sackett kyle sackett
no john do it i can hack it
rhyming about kyle sackett packing it
like a lunch slapping it like buns
uh kyle it's been a while since i've
seen your name but it always makes me
smile
it's worth the while and now i'm going
to read your
as you do this freestyle
oh perfect ally up there we're the new
beastie boys yeah
yo evening gentlemen i don't have a
remake or reboot suggestion
currently but wanted to ask a question
related to remakes and reboots or
retellings
out of the public domain property movies
robin hood king arthur etc what versions
are your favorites
out of the public domain yeah um
i would say a star sports
i would say i guess king arthur because
they do the most different ones
they're great there's never been a funny
king arthur movie like
the like the way how there was a robin
hood men in tights
yeah you got the sword and the stone but
that's totally different yeah
yeah i mean you have king arthur you got
excalibur
you have king arthur with uh berlin
and gwynevere no you got the king arthur
oh yeah king arthur excalibur uh you
have
you have the arthur what was the one
richard gere and sean connery first
night i think is what it's called
something like that where it's from the
perspective of lancelot
yeah richard gere as lancelot in that
and then king arthur is sean connery
who's like a hundred
years old in that movie you're like no
[ __ ] gwynevere wants to end up with
lancelot look how [ __ ] old he is
fair enough i think there's more variety
with king arthur and i think there's
more
melding too of intellectual properties
into the king arthur world
yeah i mean even transformers does it
yeah that's true that's the best arthur
movie
yeah um but no i mean i actually i
really like uh
antoine fuqua's director's cut of the
king arthur movie with clive owen
yeah that's a director's cut that
actually vastly improves upon it and
yeah i mean like i
i think my favorite robin hood is
probably like men in tights or or the
animated one unfortunately
and yeah i think that uh of the king
arthur properties i'm aware
of in the public domain and all that uh
of of that's the thing is besides arthur
and robin i would want to know other
public domain characters we could choose
from but i feel like yeah excalibur has
this beautiful expressionist style king
arthur has this very
period war aesthetic then you get taran
edgerton doing
the sherlock holmes movie all right uh
so yeah i think
arthur leaves you open to some cool
variety although
that means uh for me that robin hood has
the potential to improve
kyle's sex wait wait kyle sackett we're
gonna do yours again in a second
but someone's carter in the chat said
another star is born john can you put
this title over lay away
temporarily you had me thinking now of
what they should do
for another star is born you should do
the official
a star is born part two and it stars
lady gaga
and then what you do is you collide all
the other
actresses from the previous star is born
movies
because there's been four of them and
they all come together and they realize
they all share the exact same story and
there's some
weird era loop that they have to break
out of so they have to find the next
girl who's gonna be the fifth
star is born and stopped
stop the pattern from happening i
love it come on people let's get with
and that's the thing that like that
could only happen after you've remade
one movie several times
it would only make that sense how cool
that highlander did it kind of
please just write a treatment and and
make
that treatment something people in
public can see because maybe it'll get
greener there you go
i think i think i i hit the nail on the
head for what you should
this live stream was worth it alone boom
for that serious pitch
boom yes uh okay go it away all right
kyle sack it's back anisa's in the chat
anissa oh yeah
welcome back uh vega brothers tv show i
love that idea
yes indeed kyle sackett about it back it
at
kyle sackett back at it again that just
came to me
boom kyle no longer lives in denial
he's a wild child who constantly makes
sure to put
his tax portfolio in the right files
boom he's in love with harry styles oh
yeah he is
and he can run for many miles on hot
tiles
living in an era with heavy remakes
reboots i'm curious what do you feel
might be the next buddy cop movie slash
series reboot announced i wouldn't mind
another
okay i got one for you i wouldn't mind
another take on tango and cash
could do something really interesting
with today's cultural climate
now maybe another take on tango and cash
will work but no one can really replace
sylvester stallone
and um the russell
no one can ever replace those those two
guys who were in the movie
a real rejects reboot that's insulting
allison no one could ever replace
sylvester stallone and kurt russell in
the real reaches
you know how much editing they do for us
jesus my god
we just show up and get on camera um
what were we talking about we were
talking oh yeah yeah okay a buddy the
next buddy caught movie all right
i got the next buddy cop movie for you
all right
it's it's a it's about a a cop right and
he flies solo
and this guy hardcore
hetero uh homophobic hardcore homophobic
and then he develops a split personality
which is hardcore homosexual so it's
about these split personalities and this
cop
having to overcome his homophobia
because that's what the chorus is really
about
while they go on wacky adventures
in cincinnati as police officers that's
where this needs to happen
i'm telling you guys i that's i got the
ideas
that's way better than anything i could
have come up with that's
that needs to happen now we could use
feedback in the chat when we present
ideas to you guys we could use solid
feedback in the chat oh
hell's hell's to the air ricky said oh
my god we got we got feedback
uh so john do you like my buddy cop idea
i love you
i knocked it out of the park i'm not
even gonna pitch one
um eric horstmann happy belated birthday
handsome gentlemen
eric horstmann he's on the right
courseman
he's um he's not up he's not in police
enforcement
he's he's buffed like a norseman yes
uh bojack horseman
he says today non-horror
the outsiders favorite book and movie
growing up
horror happy birthday to me in april
fool's day
wow [ __ ] yeah april fool's day would be
funny
oh i remake of the outsiders
you could do it with the cast of
stranger things oh
there you go and half of the cast of it
which already has
half the cast of strangers you just
combine
all of the the current hot kids today
that sounds weird out of context you
could just take that
you could cancel me with clip culture
the current sexiest kid craig says hot
kids today
time magazines 100 sexiest children you
could do uh
yeah the outsiders with all the kids
from stranger things
that would be my that would be my pick
yeah directed by
um the guy who did wanted
they should just reboot in chapter two
and just leave the first one alone
oh this is fun this is a good idea john
thank you
wow i worked hard you had a
days without incident zero oh female
real rejects that would be interesting
katie ooh what would our female reject
names be
genevieve and greg and
actually we're more awoke by giving them
guy names yeah
names are just constructs of letters and
sounds it doesn't really matter
katy kate don't hate me yeah oh
john take it away lately i've been
thinking about
katie in haiti
where i've been relating to
people's experiences reboot beetlejuice
tank girl remake oh no no okay here we
go
reboot beetlejuice and tank girl remake
dark phoenix catwoman silent hill and
hitman
thank you for being awesome no katie
thank you for being awesome tacular
punch the camera wonder how many takes
are
jeremy john's accidentally just punching
hitting the camera
hey jenna how you doing dear ethan
holgate too in the chat
all right hello jenna randall this is
where jenna goes
notice me and i'm like we didn't uh
reboot beetlejuice okay i i
actually came up with a sequel idea with
andrew gordon
and he really wants to make this so i
can't pitch it to you
but it's okay
it's it's easily decent it's easily
all right it's easily a three out of
five i don't think you should reboot it
uh entirely but i think a sequel is what
you should do with that
a tanker remake tank girl is
a fast you know who's in it iced tea
laurie petty and laura
petty and iced tea and naomi watts
um wow way back yeah that's an old ass
[ __ ] movie i think you could totally
get away with the team i mean
you could you could make it especially
like what we've done with mad max
yeah you could totally do a tank girl
movie but have maybe like a more
whimsical mad max and it's like actually
kind of funny
well yeah i'm not familiar with the
source material of tank girl so i don't
know
well that's the thing is tank tank girl
as far as i understand has a very punky
sort of spirit about it and would
definitely leave itself open i think for
a lot more potential
off-beat humor at the very least than
any mad max absolutely
and i think yeah at a time like this a
new tank girl could actually be pretty
sweet and jamie hewlett's still
kicking man he's still very much on top
of things so
thanks john heck to the yeah let's do it
i got a question for you guys
i've got a question for you another
question for you
where'd you get your name from where'd
you get your name
from name that song
that's actually a great way to go into a
question i got a question she's going to
the song
um okay is there a time
that if we live streamed at a different
time that would be easier for you guys
because i know we totally missed most of
the uk when we do this time i mean it's
true
um anywho thanks ashton evans you're so
sweet
uh who's oh oh yeah we're looking
through the comments right now
a male hannah montana hank montana
yes and his name is willy cyrus during
the
willy cyrus
montana with billy razor that's that's
[ __ ] hysterical
oh bring back the a-team i agree okay i
got one i got one that i think you
should remake
um or at least give it another shot
uh there was a movie i was really
looking ricky said my father are you
are you responding to someone in the
chat who's saying
read something or you say reboot my
father
my father was a clone created in a lab
we need to redesign it
somebody powered him down and i've been
searching for the batteries to bring him
back
okay so um uh what were we talking about
we were uh
jumping into the chat we jumped into the
chat but oh i had one
um okay so um
one of my favorite serial killers
um was a guy named uh
richard kuklinski uh the iceman and uh
there's been like three hbo specials
about this guy
one was just like a a little documentary
about him and everyone was like a
follow-up documentary about him
and then another one was like an
interview with him and a psychologist
and then they made a movie about richard
kalinski i think it's called the iceman
and it stars michael shannon as richard
kuklinski
who's actually other than um james
gandolfini michael shannon is near
perfect casting to play
richard kuklinski but the movie is
terrible it's
terrible movie and i thought that you sh
they should do a movie or at least like
an hbo mini series about him
um because he's got a crazy lie and it's
it and and he has the kind of
kills that are not let's face it all
right you got
the serial killers like ted bunny and
it's like i don't want to see a mini
series about that guy i
did like sexual assault but richard
kalinski just murdered people
for some reason that's it is bad it's
real life but at the same time
it's it's not as there's some disturbing
kills but it's not as like
repulsive to watch in my opinion and
i think uh because he was an interesting
family man but he was a hitman at the
same time for the mafia and i think it
would be a very fascinating
um fascinating take on him starring
michael b
jordan that's richard clinton
michael sheen yes uh jack frost reboot i
see in the chat now i have a question do
you want to remake the slasher jack
frost or the michael keaton family jack
frost because i think you could do both
um oh a tiger king reboot okay uh
well like tell a new documentary or just
reboot it as a reboot i frankenstein
there you go that's reboot van helsing
we've talked about this before but i
would actually want to see that rebooted
they should
john give me your mic they should do a
follow a reboot and meet the
meet the parents or like a a sequel
okay okay yeah i don't have any ideas i
just want that
i don't know another little [ __ ] yeah
i don't really have anything
oh napoleon dynamite sequel
um okay see jenna's bringing up star
trek four with chris pine in the chat
and i'm thinking about
uh oh wait wait apple don't forget
apple's appa where's that
this is right here okay thanks do you
what
is willick okay so um
uh she's bringing up star trek four okay
and
like apparently that's falling through
so it's reaching the point where
it looks like they're probably just
going to reboot it but
would you i'm kind of thinking to myself
do i want another reboot of star trek
like the original cast
or should they try to do a new star trek
franchise
based off because all the movies are
based off of a tv show cast
yeah so i thought like if they do end up
rebooting star trek
they should just do a brand new crew
i like that idea a lot actually and that
way you could do something very
different
that being said i much rather prefer a
star trek four at the end of the day
i really do i mean it would be nice to
see that ensemble be able to send it off
in
a very clear and yes well-accepted kind
of way
yes john see you feel me john i feel you
they should also reboot by and by reboot
i mean bring back
sam raimi's spider-man franchise just
reboot part three
yes let him make the original part three
he wanted to that probably would have
been decent
okay and then who did who said what what
did i say appa said van helsing
van helsing is a great yes i've been
wanting to watch the anime show of
helsing ultimate
um i think i just wanna watch it on my
own i don't know we'll see but i've been
wanting to watch that show
and uh yeah i'm like damn they should
just really do a van helsing movie again
in the blum house universe why not i
i mean i would be curious to see what
that take is but of all the attempts to
make
these horror movies into big
swashbuckling actioners i thought that
was the best concept for it
was to do van helsing but i love
watermelon
they are you make i really do you make
watermelons look
incredible i love a good watermelon ooh
underworld would be a great remake yeah
i could see that happening
oh underworld would be perfect
yeah underworld plus you know you could
yeah because you already have like a
giant ass franchise now so you could go
back and re
do it with updated lore maybe a little
less leather
yeah i just changed the aesthetic up a
lot but i mean
i think i think what you should do with
an underworld remake is hone in more on
making it scary
yes that was because those were so heavy
action and grand i thought the action
was really cool in the first one
um and kate beckinsale's like she's just
came back and said you gotta love her
but uh but i what none of them are scary
like they're scary and aesthetic and i
feel like underworld if you redid it and
you actually made it
scary and a commentary on our times
which would not work but try it anyway
it would be cool i would still like to
see
a decent carry reboot i think that still
would lend itself even more now than it
did before my carry reboot
is my scarecrow adaptation of jonathan
crane
but as a little boy bullied dude perfect
all right never mind and then it's a
halloween dance and then he unleashes
the fear toxin
and then rawr everyone sees their worst
fears
and they're all batman
someone said uh what is that mike willis
said uh
the howling and and i think that could
be a cool reboot but also just like
getting a full-on
werewolf movie again would be sweet i
think you know what else would be cool
[Music]
would be cool too let's make a cato
movie man yeah there you go
and have seth rogen still be the
supporting character ricky's familiar
with richard kuklinski that shows you
the kind of human she is
i judge you also even though i i'm the
one who brought him up they made a whole
pitch about what you should do
i'm sure there are a bunch of horror
movies that could be rebooted but
somebody uh
asked specifically about horrors and one
franchise
that has gone on forever but i would
like to see properly rebooted hopefully
by the guy
with involvement heavy involvement from
the guy who created it was hellraiser
because that's one that's continued with
direct to video sequels for so long
and i feel like that world if you really
resurrected it
could be horrifying all right and uh
tales from the hood too
uh if they had like an actual like they
did a straight to video one a few years
ago which i heard wasn't great but i
feel like that has a lot of
stuff you can do with it and that's
actually thank you
sean it came to mind and then i was like
why there's some another thought
attached to that what's that thought oh
yeah that's right it's the movie fights
i pitched this on movie fights that
jordan peele should help
the tales from the hood reboot boogie
there you go it would be relevant for
today's times jordan appeal would be the
perfect person to back it
yeah and i won that round hey
thank you john for uh setting up a
little lower
you put the credit on the end of an
arrow and you shot it my way you went
boom here's your credit greg that was a
fun prep time
i said thanks and then i died in your
arms
died in your arms tonight the burbs
uh let's redo uh sarah campbell's
let's come up with some more rhymes for
campbell's
morgan state freshman
um just any morgan state freshman
morgan state freshman john okay
i'm thinking of this girl named morgan
who uh i i i oh god i got nothing i got
nothing
if you're uh i got nothing if you're in
harry potter and your partner's name is
burke then your name is probably borgin
um you we did it we did it billy corgan
thank you morgan what did she say
uh he she they say tron should be
a disney plus series that would be
expensive and only one streaming service
could afford it and it's disney plus
some kind of tron reboot seems cool like
a cool idea now would it be
would it be a movie of someone who
you know how they they're like they're
in the real world and they go into the
tron game
would it be a movie that's just in the
tron game and you don't get out of the
real world
or i mean for disney plus hmm you know
or
is it something or is it like digital
westworld yeah it's like digital west
cool
which is already digital in a lot of
ways
you're just not actually there oh i
would love that
pixels now actually that's not a bad
idea thanks morgan state freshman yeah
good call
keep on studying those books mr vaju
boy do i love you i find it to be true
and people always
rhyme the words you and true and two and
pooh and dew and jew
and mew too and the new clue
sup fellas i would love to see a weird
science reboot
that would be perfect for today's times
maybe you would vanessa hudgens
tones down her annoyingness vanessa we
got
the test results back from the screening
people mostly liked it but they want you
to tone down your annoyingness
maybe weird science the your reboot
should be about that they make vanessa
hudgins
and she's so [ __ ] annoying to this
guy named mr vaju who's the main
character
that's and he's like how do we get rid
of her [ __ ] annoyingness
that's what it'll be it'll be some kind
of allegory where like the more
these boys tweak their designer woman
and make her like you know the most
oogly picturesque thing the more hurt
like whenever they
make her more physically desirable her
mind just gets more and more annoying to
compensate for it
it could be a commentary on mansplaining
yeah i'm just like no one will want to
spend any time with you if you behave
this way not even a woman you created on
a computer don't get me wrong
two guys should write this movie
definitely they should and they should
direct it too
and they should probably play every role
it should be a commentary about
mansplaining
and about how it it's perfectly fine
well because
men do the mansplaining so who better to
write about
who better to teach i'm just kidding
um jordan metz
jordan metz you can bet that
i love you like uh
who john lovetts yeah in jordan
never borin and uh
whenever i talk to jordan i never start
snoring
he's saying galaxy of terror what the
[ __ ] is this galaxy a terror
oh my god john type we should reboot
terror vision
type galaxy of terror into the google's
search engine you got this take your
time
take your time no typos you did it okay
it's a 1981 film that you could watch on
hbo max apparently
well there you go that's why you should
sign up directed by
produced by roger corman okay cool on a
desolate storm lash planet called
morgenthas
the last survivor of a crashed spaceship
is attacked and killed by an
undead crew okay you know what i've
heard enough
make this reaper doing hbo max
dooms up with disney plus to make this
series
i agree they should do a streaming wars
movie
it should be about them thinking if they
should launch hbo max and they do and
it's just oh this is not as promising as
anyone thought it would
make up for lost ground although i have
seen the first three seasons of rick and
morty
because of hbo max and was really
bumming i'm like
where's season four and then i bought it
right away i was like [ __ ] hbo max
they don't have season four on hbo max
no but they got the first three seasons
interesting
kartik sharma i don't
want to alarm you but you're getting a
shout out
and you might need a prescription from
the pharma
see what he did there see pharma see
what he did
there you can't act like you don't care
when i wear out all these rhymes
he says john hughes remakes
taxi driver good fellas
wolf of wall street scorsese
remakes home alone breakfast club
ferris bueller's day off okay
all right if john hughes remade taxi
driver
that could be a weird romantic film
yes it would but you know if he remade
it back then it would be fine
if he redid goodfellas it would be they
would all be
romantic comedies first of all where the
men learn and grow up
they don't have the downfall that they
have here in these movies
um and scorsese if he read it home alone
that would be a crazy finale yeah
yeah that would be gruesome oh man
if he didn't read reflective breakfast
love in ferris state
that would be great i like your idea
kartik thank you
um oh wait a minute someone in the chat
said something interesting
female scarface definitely starring brie
larson
everyone would watch it release it on
youtube exclusively
yes i'm down
uh let's see here tariq allen tariq
allen palin around with tariq allen as
he goes on jimmy fallon
and uh hangs out with joseph stalin
good that's good we good buffy the
vampire slayer
we cover that yeah but you should make
weren't they making a buffy the vampire
slayer remake i thought they were doing
that with a woman of color
that's not a gen sounds like i'm making
a joke but it's not a joke
i thought they were they could remaking
buffy with a woman of color i mean
i could see it happening and by color i
mean blue eyes and blonde hair
yeah those are colors definitely and she
got she got a tan so she got a little
color
um i i vaguely remember hearing
something about this and that would be
fine actually i would like that better
if they just don't
i would honestly just make it somebody
else the vampire
slayer and use the the vampire slayer as
the connective tissue because the thing
about buffy the vampire slayer is there
are other slayers in the show
and some of them terrible parts are not
terrible points you're making john
just gotta say i'm gonna shoot down your
points right now my only thing about
remaking buffy though is that we have
like the thing is you had supernatural
for so long filling that void and
and other like i feel like the buffy
void
has been full for a long time and so
i'm a little curious about how we would
reboot it right this minute
if not for the original cast all right
that's fair you know
john i like where your head's at and i
appreciate you for the human being
that you are likewise d.o.g and lanya
barnett
happy birthday happy b day dominic
zeph zaffiri dominic
is uh uh oh god damn it
um um um zafiri crawling out the lake
like inferior oh harry potter
i think cracking jokes like dennis leary
um uh clearly
we have rhymed enough uh dominic
safiri says remake escape from new york
with john carpenter helming the score so
do like a halloween reboot thing
i've they've been working on an escape
from new york remake with
uh gerard butler for like 10 years now
i think they should remake it with jason
momoa now
or let's let's give jeremy render one
more shot at taking over a franchise
just just give him
escape from new york or dave chappelle
one of the two i think would be great
dave chappelle's escape from new york is
definitely what i want
the best jack burton or no that's a big
trouble sorry snake pliskin
they should do escape from new york but
or or just a really
boring state like escape from new york
with covet or escape from north dakota
yeah you know escape from delaware
escape
came from new hampshire escape from
cities that that aren't that popular
escape from the tri-county area there's
no one here there hasn't been anyone
here ever since we shut it
way before we shut it down way before we
walled it up there hasn't been anything
out you these people have lived here way
before we put the walls up here
should we do one more from tariq before
we move back to the thing
tariq says kill bill part 3 and friends
reunion
in the same property in the same thing
you know
because tarantino loves references you
know
you can have all the friends enter the
room but whenever they enter the room
people don't cheer on the laugh track it
just plays that
song from ironside but okay
a kill bill 3 is one that you know i've
wanted forever a
friend's reunion i think you would
you know there's one there's a sitcom
that you kids might not know of called
coupling coupling no as a sitcom you
guys might not know of
that some people don't know the mary
tyler moore show
oh the shadow should be remade uh
the mary tyler moore show and then they
did a spin-off of it that was a
continuation
called lou grant and mary tyler moore
show was one of
the biggest shows in history like it's
it's the major sitcom live studio
audience
and then they did this you know
journalism
drama called lou grant and that
was a hard-hitting drama from the same
main guy from the mary tyler moore show
all right
i know that had never been done before
and it worked
it won a bunch of awards the lou grant
show oh damn
now you should do that with friends
you should do a hard-hitting drama
about ross and rachel as a domestically
violent couple who just
never made it worse she represents him
for holding back her dreams of going to
france
yeah exactly all that would catch up to
them
be like break conversation will come
back the entire time you were thinking
of going to france rachel you never
once brought up what we were going to do
with emma you do that kind of dial oh
man it could be a great one oh my god
imagine it's going to be
awesome a hard-hitting drama and then do
a crossover with how i met your mother
great call john great call
all right okay so let's go back to the
the stream here all right guys speed
round time of what we got
speed round oscar bait the movie sounds
[ __ ] hilarious
love you carter green light that [ __ ]
after earth remake
fear let's do it dark man remake
yeah that'd be fun that would be great
that'd be perfect
yeah bring sam raimi back and liam the
phantom remake
yes i that was literally what the shadow
made me think of
do the phantom remake do it oh [ __ ]
make a sequel
bring back billy zane where's his pretty
face been reboot blacula
oh there you go a seinfeld and friends
crossover
perhaps perhaps sign friends law and
order
ross and rachel
a show about her divorce there you go
oh has that been done prop wants to
watch that weekly
and there was marriage story the show
was there a show that was just called
the divorce
i think so something like that oh buddy
a live action avatar the last airbender
okay let's see live action treasure
planet the missed two there you go
looking in the chat people what have you
got action hero
dragon ball z with zack snyder
now that would work visually be great
yeah we don't know tonal story wise
but visually you know he could pull that
[ __ ] off yeah and i mean all of my
granted i didn't ever watch it as much
as everybody else did but my greatest
recollections of the show are pretty
angsty
so i feel like zack snyder would be able
to handle that oh my god have you had
like a zack snyder fight of goku and
vegeta
fighting each other
and also the charge up sequences where
people are just screaming for half the
movie would be so badass in slow-mo
the ellen show reboot oh my god oh
yes now especially is the time for that
and she could be on her way out
there's a lot of crap i mean they're the
there's actual lawsuits that are being
put in the headlines you know yeah
headlines today
ellen's a [ __ ] allen's not training our
employees well
ellen isn't as great as we all thought
she was oh goodness
i had one but then it left my brains oh
my god they should do like oh okay
bradley in the chat saying thompson take
engine
nolan style reboot okay i got one for
you thomas
the tank engine but danny boyle style
here's my pitch
it's a hundred and twenty eight hours or
days later whatever the [ __ ] that
movie's in 120
what the [ __ ] is james franco seven
hours 127 hours
128 days later 327 hours
with thomas the tank engine he's just on
the tracks
the engine dials
off he has to cut his coal car no way he
can get back on the tracks
he's gotta sever his coal cars we can
get out of here
who wouldn't want to see that come on i
want it
see you guys fuel the live stream guys
we've got us
we've already had a power rangers reboot
i want a reboot of vr troopers
who remembers vr troopers uh yeah i do
ryan was the main guy ryan the blonde
hair blue eyed
guy he was great beatleborgs that's what
i want a reboot of
they should do an origin tale of jack
dawson from titanic
just how he got that boat ticket
uh street fighter reboot there you are
someone after your own exactly street
fighter remake
yeah i've said it countless times in the
stream final fantasy
the spirits within oh okay all right we
got
these are great picks guys what else do
we got in here okay fortnite movies not
a reboot we gotta stick to the reboots
trust me we you guys keep pitching every
once in a while
our brains will come up with something
that's passable
you know i would be i would be so so
apprehensive
so apprehensive about a they live reboot
but
if it was done well i would love that
i would love that yeah you know like
that movie is is like that movie is
fun and campy but it also gets more
relevant with time you know i don't want
them to reboot terminator
but i want them to reboot terminator
dark fate
that's yeah nothing to do they should
start rebooting bad seek
promises yeah start from there reboot
yeah exactly
reboot the waste of uh of potential oh
my god i still want my jack dawson
titanic movie show
jack dawson titanic show produced by
ryan murphy
for netflix yes get that period piece in
there make it a musical too
why is this movie a horror story i don't
understand
early american horror story yeah no more
terminator
i'm i'm down for that fine no more
terminator fine
mortal kombat is getting a reboot you
don't need to keep asking it's already
starship troopers that would be fun
starship troopers would be a great
reboot that'd be perfect
and get somebody who who doesn't
understand the satirical edge of the
original movie
yeah like how they do with robocop yeah
exactly
that would be perfect straightforward
yeah oh goodness that robocop remake
isn't that bad but i still would would
rather see neil blomkamps for a book
coverage absolutely
or neil blomkamp's alien five let neil
blomkamp reboot everything
they should remake jesus christ
superstar
yeah it's a it's better with the
lin-manuel miranda
hey jesus christ superstar the rap
musical
should i get off this cross or should i
listen to my boss my boss father up my
mom
my brother's father of time
[Laughter]
miranda's christ oh my god it would be
perfect
oh we can cast this whole thing with
hamilton yeah just get the entire cast
of hamilton
to be digging
he was already black in the first jesus
christ superstar
oh was he oh that's [ __ ] up never mind
yeah i take it back oh god damn it john
i want the most
aryan actor to remember my the jesus
christ superstar
only white actor is judas how about that
female passion of the christ oh my gosh
they are rebooting candyman yeah
it's coming out at some point joel i
love your pick
iron fist should absolutely be remade
it's just we live in a weird world where
i want all the marvel netflix characters
to stay the same for the mcu now
but i really wouldn't mind if they
replace finn jones it's a weird thing
yeah just do that iron man 2 thing you
look different
need a haircut or something did you do
that wait did you get asian just
santa buddy
dark universe reboot with ryan gosling
has every monster now that
they've already done a male showgirls
it's called the real rej
it's called magic mike [ __ ]
um yeah okay all right uh we could
reboot them we could reboot
they we could reboot it
sorry somebody said don't lose the
quality of the stream
quality might be remake show girls two
pennies from heaven
okay thanks bruce wayne appreciate that
hey
a push reboot all right guys we can't
how far are we behind on the super chats
are we approaching an hour let's get
down to business
they should reboot the mulan song
but every time they do that
they should have al pacino's voice go in
the mulan song and go
whoa that hat is a viral video waiting
to happen
that we can produce right we should make
that video we will make it in five
minutes
i can see the title now be a man but
every huawei is al pacino there was only
one who
won you know what we'll help adam in
even more who was we got percy trembling
trembling oh percy tremblet
um thanks percy okay okay this is going
off his scoob
uh a scoob reboot idea um
and i believe this is this little scoob
is like a riverdale style yep
all right [ __ ] yeah let's [ __ ] do
this okay
percy please show some mercy
and you see me at my worst bruce lee
but we won't respond tersly to your
comment
shaggy should be a lycan who changes to
scoob
and have a silly inner dialogue yes john
explain to the chat what a liken is and
by
john explaining to the chat what a
liking just simultaneously explaining to
me
what a lycan is oh yeah well lykan is
just a fancy word for werewolf like
anthropos somebody is a
person i knew that because i saw
underworld there you go yeah
and i [ __ ] forgot yeah god damn it
lycanthropy is uh
just the uh state and practice of being
a werewolf and transforming
uh but that would be cool shaggy should
be a liking to changes to scoop i would
be down for that
and that would actually you know i would
be down for that that would make a great
group
i would be down for that
i would be down for that it would make
a great film or first season arc because
think of it
think of it there are all these killings
and stuff or whatever you know
it would be harder sure because it's
riverdale but you know everyone's like
we gotta find this wolf
but then it's revealed like one of those
movies where the twist is it's him the
whole time that
this is a twist and then the sequel or
the second season will be about shaggy
learning to harness his inner scoob
john you are the greatest human being i
have ever met
based off that idea i mean yes i think
so next to
um uh tyrone magnus you are the second
greatest human being i've ever met
you're like right behind akkason and i'm
dante
oh my god don't put me in their league
okay especially you're right behind no
life
um tariq allen he's saying give me a
shout out
tariq to tariq
don't let your life go bleak oh my god
my ears hurt is that a shriek
uh let's go play hide and seek as i find
your last name and it's alan
going on jimmy fallon we're doing this
again
thank you tariq you're so sweet wookie's
kind of working
squeaky squeak squeak uh sarah
campbell's back
sarah campbell thank you so much sarah
campbell you're a beautiful darling oh
not bad actually remakes stay alive stay
alive
with a better story and less frankie
munich yeah the the evil video game
movie from way back
don't you dare [ __ ] on my frankie muniz
yeah don't you
dare [ __ ] on my frankie let's reboot
malcolm in the middle they're gonna be
doing a reunion
via zoom pretty soon and i would love
to get in on that because one time they
filmed malcolm in the middle
in uh the neighborhood i grew up on on
bessemer street in north hollywood
and uh my dad knew the producer so
frankie muniz's dressing room at the
time
was this one's bedroom oh damn yeah had
a very
awkward conversation with the guy yeah
we didn't really get along
that was he was kind of socially awkward
i was socially awkward because i was
like why the [ __ ] is my dad having me
forcing me to talk to him
uh i'm not gonna like be friends with
this guy afterwards he's [ __ ] frankie
muniz malcolm in the middle is a huge
show
so my bottom line is to be friends with
me don't [ __ ]
on frankie [ __ ] munis don't
[ __ ] on lockhart's buddy holly but
sarah campbell what i will add to that
is stay alive would have been a lot
better with less frankie muniz
i'm just saying remakes so i can't
disagree with you remake stay alive
remake fear.com
uh remake that other one this cry wolf
remake all those yeah they should also
remake besides stay alive they should
remake staying alive
oh yeah with john john travolta the
follow up to saturday night fever that
stallone directed that solo
wrote and directed jesus
and when you if you watch saturday night
fever and then you watch
staying alive you're like what the [ __ ]
is this movie
but once you say stallone wrote and
directed this in the 80s you're like
ah
and on my gums um beautiful
but thank you sarah campbell you rock
you rock
roll r b beautiful bliss bliss kiss miss
dismiss oh we rhymed you beautiful
whimsical um equivocal equivocal
dragon ball z live action movie reboot
we just pitched that with zack snyder at
the helm because someone in the chat
said that but still
starting justin by danny unchained or
remake i'll take
either as long as they stick to its
world a dragon ball z
live action movie is something that is
that is something that
can be pulled off or live action show
they should try to remake some anime
movies or you know how they're adapting
anime
they should try to make some of them tv
shows like live action in the style
that would work a lot better i think i
think starting off there they might have
a better
shot at actually pulling it off yeah
especially
in it just seems so much smarter now
that especially we've watched so many
more anime
to adapt something that's really long
into a really long format yes
enough of this trying to cram four
seasons into a movie
oh my god okay thrips are in the chat i
see yours i'm writing yours down
mark leach i like yours too i'm writing
that
down oh and nissan thank you oh we got a
niece
anisa oliver lean on me like the tower
of pisa
or cheese never been diagnosed with
chlamydia
but once had a scare that it might have
been gonorrhea oh yeah
but it wasn't like dropped fantastic
four but actually right this time
not like those [ __ ] before yeah i
mean they're doing it
i think i think they're gonna do it
don't you fret
they're made they're gonna do another
fantastic four
and it's gonna be awesome all right it's
gonna be
mrs and mrs fantastic it's gonna be a
lesbian company this is
fantastic and then they're gonna have
um mx fantastic they're gonna joe
rogan's gonna play the thing
actually will poulter will be human
torture
it's gonna be good i love it you got
this
thank you anisa you're so sweet eric are
you at work right now
so you should be focusing on your work
she's got her phone propped up on a
patient right now
perfect eric horseman's back salem's
lot cause it was an awesome tv mini
series but needs a blockbuster movie
version
change my mind all right i'll change
your mind
i think salem's lot was perfect as a tv
series and i don't see how you can
properly
adapt that into a feature length movie
granted all i wanted to do was try to
change your mind
i've never seen sales so i can't really
comment on it
but someone out there might agree with
my fake opinion
and that is how most politics are
decided upon
and we consume the watermelon
boom jordan metz is
back jordan metz not to be confused with
kevin smith's just putting a showdown
rhyme in there
a live-action remake of treasure planet
uh this has been brought up in the past
and i have personally
been [ __ ] pioneering for this
treasure planner remake forever i'm
gonna if ever somebody asks what the
most underrated disney animation movie
is i guess that's gonna be
atlantis oh oh that's wait
treasure no church plan is dude okay
atlantis is dizzy i don't care
it is i think you're right oh no i'm
sure i'm i'm thinking of tightening
ease that's disney i'm thinking of final
fantasy the spirits within that that's
what definitely that's what i'm thinking
of that's
that's what i'm thinking of treasure
planet uh live action reboot though i
would be definitely i would be down four
and uh anissa is std free as i said i
ended that shout out with saying you
don't have an std
all right yeah if you wind the tape back
rewind it back
listen carefully never said you had it
ramiro
sanchez oh ramiro
is hanging out with robert de niro
like sucked off al pacino like a hero
and then hung out and made some laughs
with ray romano
joe pesci ahsoka tano
just joined the live stream don't know
if it's been said but
masters of the universe aren't they
remaking masters of the universe they
got it isn't there a show already i
thought kevin smith is working on it oh
maybe
are they doing an animation i know he's
got an animated show coming up but
yeah i'm pretty sure he's doing yeah
he's doing that i i heard not long ago
that i'm trying to cast e-man right
yeah exactly that's what i'm talking
about all right so you're gonna get your
wish
you're gonna get get your wish but if
it's an animated show maybe you do want
like an actual
live action movie so you can get that
diaper and page boy haircut combo like
full-on
which i i don't blame you plus
live-action skeletor would be cool
and then try doing a show a live action
show
yeah wasn't there a live action show hey
john how's that novel coming along
hey brian how's that novel coming home
brian um
uh three ninjas reboot not bad not bad
at all happy belated birthday jean jeter
my homeboy
jeter thanks ricky that's really sweet
of you to say yeah
mds omega mds omega
maybe a beetlejuice oh wait wait john
john
omega omega thought he had gone
real but it was actually chlamydia
omega alpha watching uh
preacher with ruth nega nice um
rutabaga new vega number
they get a stop can do
maybe a beetlejuice remake okay look if
you remade beetlejuice
you gotta do it with jared leto because
let's just face it it would be the
perfect excuse to ruin a beetlejuice
remake
but watch in trying to do so he would do
an amazing job
i think i never thought being in jail
could pull this off the
secret is gonna be that beetlejuice is a
repulsive character we're not acting
like he's endearing in a way but
you know he's not actually like likable
and so
jared let out his joker like that kind
of like yeah if he went
full ham like he did with the joker i
bet it would probably be better suited
to that movie
you knocked a shot to park on that one
john thanks g enjoy that watermelon oh
my gosh
i should go watermelon anisa just
hearing you talk
with it in your mouth is making me want
one
that's which is one of the few times
that's happened to me anissa's back
how rudolph i feel the same way when you
suck dick oh
oh and oh i talk while i'm doing it oh i
know it's rude that's what i'm thinking
the entire time i'm watching you
do your job
i'm not going to continue that hi how
how rude of me hi greg hi
john how are you all doing today you're
even better now
how was your week hi nisa i don't want
to fight with you by the way
love to see your beautiful faces love
you all so much and shout out to my
discord family
all right how rude of me very rude of
you you're rude how are we doing today
doing good right now i'm doing all right
right now forget how fun the livestream
i i always forget how fun the live
streams are until we're
live streaming then i'm like oh yeah
before and after
especially after right now like why the
[ __ ] did we laugh
that's a bunch of energy i'll never get
back
don't listen to us we're just joshing ya
actually no we were like it was pretty
tense before uh we got we went live
because
i shot a video with david henry
that i but this is a special video that
i have to
you'll see when it comes out next week
um that has to get approved
first before i can make it public um and
that took me a long dave henry from
wizards of waverly place and so i have
to this whole
there's it was a long edit basically it
was shot for like 30 minutes and i
really had to trim the [ __ ] out of it
and stuff
and then also editing for umbrella
academy normally we
have um other yeah that's david in case
you don't know
who david is yeah yeah there you go
there we go
we got a lot of david jesus to come
that's what it looks like
um so uh what was it what was it going
to say olivia said we've had this
convert before and i'm like what the
[ __ ] she's talking about
well we were talking about the week and
david oh she said i can hear you i'll
talk about sucking dick in there again
okay okay i think the key word sucking
dick is blocked because we've talked so
much about it
yes that her comment wasn't shown so
babe i just made it live for you
yeah it's public now now you can hear
about that you can talk about as much
john and i sucking dick as much as you
want there's actually a bunch of videos
on here of us discussing only that that
just get blocked on youtube
and so editing for umbrella academy um
i've never
this is the first time i've committed to
like okay i gotta edit myself for
a tv show to put up on youtube which is
a lot more strict than what we've been
doing on patreon
so um and that that's those like i'm
like wow editing the watch along and
and the highlights that and then like
the thumb doing the thumbnails for that
all that crap
it's taking like five to six hours per
video and i made a promise to get them
up every
other day so it's just i i
i've been doing five to six extra hours
a day with the editing
and wow this is really tiring so before
going live
there's like stuff we hadn't gotten done
yet that we have to finish after this
stream so we do have to end by seven
today
and uh so we're like oh should we cancel
the stream because there's so much to do
but then you know five minutes into
being live here
i was like you know what yeah these live
streams are a blast i can forget that so
this is actually a great way to
de-stress
and then um come back to the to the
editing programs
yeah yeah yeah yeah well and and again
you know do
do something that's still you know like
we're on camera but it's totally loose
and fun
yeah anyway that's how we're [ __ ]
doing it nisa thank you
yeah shout out to the discord family and
someone in the chat
said what they say about the original
they
said okay this has been an ongoing i saw
this pop up
bro this is uh chic niner
bro thank you for showing me the ridge
wallet oh my god and i love your show
and i see your ridge wallet i i love the
idea that we are the first people to
tell someone about the original
piece yeah if you didn't hear it on the
needle drop you heard it
i love it i love that i i
adore this thing everyone i'll link it
in the description of this video but
find one of our videos of the ridge wall
and get yourself a discount because
these things are
awesome or if you don't find a discount
through us of course we prefer if you
did we don't benefit if we don't get
like a commission if you use our
discount
but if you find any youtuber with a
discount for the ridge wallet
yeah take advantage of that because oh
[ __ ] i love that [ __ ]
but it i don't know in a residual way it
helps us maybe they'll advertise with us
again if we get a lot of people clicking
that link
maybe this is
behind the scenes strategy for you guys
to remake the last airbender movie
but to be good yes that
i have an idea to remake the last
airbender let's make it
good this time that's what we missed the
last time
why did we set out with a completely
different intention to make
people mad what the [ __ ] were we
thinking what gives
uh yeah good call reboot glass
while we're rebooting shyamalan joining
oh
yeah he has he has the original rights
to the intellectual property
it was his his idea here he created
avatar the last hamburger what are you
talking about
all right dream chaser man let's not go
at all mean when we're talking about our
dreams as we gleam
upon this live stream with dream chaser
we gotta
have a bit of a pacer with all these
rhymes
before i run out of [ __ ] to say hey guys
remake of transformers would be
awesome hey guys i got a bumblebee
but that's not a remake of actually yeah
they were setting themselves up to
remake transformers
yeah i mean basically because think
about it the first transformers movie is
about a kid discovering bumblebee
yeah that'd be great yeah uh yeah i mean
at this point anybody else's
transformers would be a fascinating
prospect to me
yes i only know what travis knights
looks like
other than michael bay's i would i would
be down for a transformers roommate i
think a lot of people would
do do we enjoy umbrella academy i
[ __ ] love umbrella academy
someone earlier said remake dark phoenix
and i'm like umbrella academy season one
took care of that already and why are
people talking about fighting me in the
chat specifically
my girlfriend and olivia and how uh
my girlfriend and olivia my girlfriend
olivia and anisa
and uh they're talking about kicking my
ass and uh how anissa can be of course a
niece can
beat me up have you seen me
these muscles are just for show they're
all yeah
we had a special filter that just makes
you look that way i'm even skinnier than
real
yeah i am sickly this is all an app
you're looking at right now
this is face app but for muscles and i'm
not using it
hamish murray hamish murray
talk about a danish furry
that's what haynes murray is he's a
danish furry hurry i'm getting a little
blurry
by this danish flurry right now oh my
god you got me all
wary with your rhymes a little scurry
incredibles live action remake ooh
it's it's gonna be the fantastic four
one
yeah with slightly different powers yes
just yes oh my god wait she
okay i love your idea hanish i
appreciate the super chat
thank you all right guys we're almost
caught up on the super chats right
wow we're doing killer killer numbers we
got some stream labs we got to cover too
we gotta go to the laboratory
but someone in the chat said did you see
the new tweet of stefan wolfe
steppenwolf on snyder tweets looks bad
off haven't seen it yet
yeah that's a new character steffen
wolfe don't want to get compared to the
sn to the joss whedon cut man
this is his brother and he's even
battering everyone's getting a slight
rename here
cyber wonder woman with a w instead of
an o and wonder
wonder one dear woman super guy
um all right that was great um john
needs a shampoo commercial
ooh john used to use some shampoo
all that dandruff flying around the
goddamn room all day
that's what we clean off of the surfaces
it's not regular
i haven't heard that name in ages they
should reboot the show cops they should
show cops right now right now
uncensored oh buddy if there was just a
channel that played
body cam footage imagine what our
society would be like
i'm sure it exists somewhere out there
john on the deep web
um okay let's see here i don't know why
i sounded like that
face off reboot there you go but still
get nicolas cage
maybe one day we will do more ryan
george pitch meetings but i kind of
share that show with my girlfriend now
and i share that show with myself yeah
this one's for me
and that one's for me that's how some
some stuff has to just be from
for for you know like there are some
shows i just won't cover on youtube
because i'm like no this show's for me
let's not worry about anyone thinking of
things about me john and gray go to
white castle i love that
i would love a white castle right now oh
john several actually
one isn't enough yeah you have to it's
the only burger place where it's like
acceptable to order
like eight burgers we got to catch up on
some of these
stream laps because we got a heart out
by seven
so hard so hard hard work hard
they should remake heart no never remake
walk re-release it and say it's new
all right yeah you could probably get
away with that reboot uh
friggin bohemian rhapsody ethan holgate
a man that sometimes likes to masturbate
while he licks his own taint ethan
don't you're a beacon of light
[ __ ] hi
guys i think a lawnmower man remake
and a last starfighter remake would make
great remakes nowadays because they have
awesome sci-fi concepts that will work
nowadays
and i think those movies would make
great remakes in general
i'd want to see them would you yeah i
mean i'm not
not as familiar with last star fighter
as i am with lawnmower man
but i think lawnmower man should
absolutely be remade or just do a follow
up with pierce brosnan with updated
special effects i think you can get away
with an updated lawnmower if you guys
haven't seen lawnmower man
you guys should watch lawnmower don't
disturb yourself lawnmower man is one of
the greatest movies ever made
yeah easily i i it's one of those rare
great movies that i would go
yeah remake that great movie
even though it's already perfect yes
[ __ ] remake
perfect remaking so more people know
about lawnmower man and make sure that
remake is bad
that way people go and watch the
original and go wow that one's good
lawnmower man peace out the other thing
is i would want to remake lawn mower man
but i'd be a little
afraid of remaking the last starfighter
because it's so beloved
it's such a beloved film for for so many
young people
john get rid of your dandruff
aye aye
she said forgot to write more than my
first name before
reboot spawn with better special effects
they
are rebooting spawn katie they are
rebooting it and it's going to be
great blumhouse todd mcfarlane because
you look guys
let's face it the hellboy remake was so
much better
when you had the original graphic not
the the creator of the comics
actually involved in the process of the
movie tote bags it ban out great
and now with todd mcfarlane even more
involved in the live action spawn reboot
guaranteed it's going to be better i
can't see what i did i just can't
i'm teaching a class on sarcasm later um
but thank you katie ann
sign up nerf mac you know who nerf mac
is do you know who nerf mac is i just
learned this
cameron [ __ ] french oh
wow this is this is great we have a
direct line team this is how this is our
cameron
instagram messages us here's how we
message he
like he's a big fan i didn't realize he
was nerf mac here
the reboots i want max payne terminator
3
thank you katherine bigelow strange
range
venom i like street hellboy star wars
prequel trilogy the ref
paycheck all right i'm going to speed
round this bad boy
max payne absolutely should be remade
would be great terminator 3.
we already covered that strange days
um i don't know yet come back change
days are pretty
decent already venom i i think down the
road we will already
let's face it there's already a reboot
that's gonna happen at some point
eventually
so you're gonna be honored hellboy i
still want that part three
star wars prequel trilogy let's add on
the kathleen
kennedy trilogy the ref
don't know that one paycheck um
i was thinking of payback with mel
gibson uh paycheck
yeah let's do paychecks why the [ __ ] no
back check
i love it i love it cameron and i love
you cameron
nerf mac with the back at it with the
with the worf
and then katie and it's also saying re
make the ring with streaming services
instead of v how do you but wait a
minute wait a minute okay hold on let me
read the rest of this
remake the ring with streaming services
instead of vhs tapes therefore
globalizing the terror
appreciate all the energy you put into
what you do and how much joy it brings
into my life
oh thanks katie anne i don't do this for
you
i do it for john i just want john i
really appreciate it i mean all the
years of this
have really made me feel great god
it's the only thing that keeps me going
that's really sweet katie wait a minute
though
isn't okay so you want to remake the
ring but you can't remake
you can't do it with streaming services
because isn't the whole point of
the tape right click and copy the file
yeah like
you're supposed to pass it along right
so if you just put it on a streaming
service
everyone just gets access to it that's
the beautiful thing about a streaming
service but how that
that would work against the whole
concept of the ring well there was a
horror movie i wanted to make a long
time ago you know one of those like
you got to make it right now before this
isn't relevant anymore of like you know
one of those email
chain letters that used to go around
where it's like if you don't forward
this to 20 people i'm gonna kill you
i feel like you could tech reboot the
ring that way
uh but if it's just like a streaming
service it almost seems like you would
have to get rick rolled to watch it
yeah like i mean unless they're like you
have to share your account
like hey i noticed we should only use
this on three devices
and actually you know would be great
will work in terms of marketing though
for the streaming service of the ring is
if you get all the streaming services to
agree to
to fund it that way they could all be on
each one of the streaming services
that way i don't have to [ __ ] get
peacock now
to watch the harry potter movies oh
because what a bunch of [ __ ]
like why do these streaming services
launch and only have their movies for
like
a month and they're like but now it's
going to this other one
now it's corners and i'm like i just got
the streaming service
welcome to the age where you throw your
hands up and go back to casey
son of a [ __ ] son of a [ __ ] oh
goodness i mean the thing too
is i would investigate that most recent
ring film because i think they did some
digital stuff in that movie but uh
oh mimi she wants to date the hobbits
keely and feely
yes and she hung out with my boss at my
hot dog restaurant called willie
and he was so silly and she got a
cheesesteak
mimi and it was from philly
she wore a suit that would look like
leaves we got it we gotta preserve these
in case someone else has a
uh name or an e we gotta preserve some
of these rhymes you know there's only
so much in the noggin maybe for tv show
reboots i wanna see
pushing daisies yeah timeless and brain
dead with tony shalhoub we are already
getting a boondocks reboot
on hbo john take this one away you're a
huge pushing daisies fan i mean huge
daisies fans so john
tell them why it would be good
essentially because it was a show that
had a lot of heart and imagination and
an interesting twist on a sort of
supernatural crime procedural and it
didn't last as long as
it's just one of those textbook examples
of a show that had so much potential and
was
pretty good in its first season and
didn't get enough viewers so i would
totally be down and jim dale by ricky
who does the harry oh by ricky
uh jim dale who narrates the harry
potter audio books at least
from before is the narrator and he's got
such a great voice so
he's the narrator on the show so even
more mimi you're perfect did i just
close out the window i think so
john bring it back let's bring it back
really quick i ruined
the live stream i'm gonna look at the
chat see what's going on there
pewdiepie is a reboot okay didn't see
that john you're gonna do this
okay i didn't mean to [ __ ] but i had
to
accept safari in order to do this and
we should get higher engagement on when
people say bye yes
so whoever when you leave the stream say
bye yes
yes we will acknowledge you always say
goodbye
you got so many people just coming in
just to say bye yes
say you know is poke your head in and
say what's up
and then say goodbye oh goodness should
we go back to the stream labs yes we
gotta we gotta make sure we're on track
we got we got a heart out
dos moss we got eric horstmann
remake thank you eric my god you with
your crazy ass contributions i really
appreciate it dude
too generous love you buddy remake the
last starfighter with guest cameo by
lance guest okay
okay i think the last starfighter reboot
is going to happen because
i have seen this [ __ ] movie brought
so many times during this last year like
so many times
not just in the super chats and the
stream lab contributions but also
in the regular um chat too it's gonna be
another word other than regular
in the uh uh the youtube channel
the youtube chat the yeah it's called
that the youtube chat
yeah let's call it youtube chat every
other word sounds like degrading i don't
like that
it's worth jesus let's stop the stream
and let's start talking this through and
we'll come back with a proper name
the new lexicon of words yes guys this
is the first stream that hasn't [ __ ]
blocked out in the middle of us
streaming
isn't that great i mean this is the
right started this is a relatively
low impact stream yeah remake the last
star fighter
uh with guest cameo by lance guest and
hey i mean last star fighter 2 the the
effects are probably dated but uh and
knight of the comic with cameo by
catherine mary
stewart don't know the movies why the
[ __ ]
no i was gonna say i have no idea what
the hell these movies
are wait wait wait wait wait wait night
of the comic
we do neither the comic or not of the
comet
because i have seen knight of the
comment and that is an 80s
knight of the comic stars um i believe
that actually stars rodney dangerfield
oh okay
and it was him taking a dramatic role
exploring
the dramas of being a stand-up comic
um reboot rover dangerfield no it's nine
of the comet uh aaron was wrong eric is
drunk eric is pissed drunk again
she's eric geez eric you're so drunk you
can't even type
can't even type you get him to say the
word type greg
you're so drunk you're making me drunk
night of the comment
night of the comment you know that's
what yeah i know that movie john
tell them about it i mean it's fun it's
a movie about yeah there's just like
these comments rained down and it like
wipes out a good amount of earth's
population there these like mutants
around and stuff like that and uh
that sounds fun it is totally eric
horseman's kind of movie yeah
and actually on this is an example of a
movie that i wasn't wild about the first
time i saw it and then the second time i
saw it i was like oh yeah i see the
charm because it's this girl and her
sister i think or her friend or whatever
who are like kind of the leads and who
are
the main people stuck in this situation
um
so yeah i mean catherine mary stewart
i've seen her at a convention before i
want to say
so uh yeah freaking a why not bring her
back
all right you did it was it kelly
moroney i'm not sure
oh well but yeah you know it doesn't
matter if it was katherine stewart or
kelly moroney who you saw
at this convention because it's all in
your memory
so you could lie you could say you saw
donald trump at a convention and it
could just be something you're saying
i i watched an interview no way anyone
could fact check you on this
i watched a leonard winner a leno
interview damn it eric you're making us
all drunk a leno interview with trump
from like 10
or more like 20 years ago it was
fascinating
it was very different than what i yeah
expected
genki and the chat has seen it would be
fun to chat with us i want you to know
jinky it's in real life it's not in real
life
this is all for the performance we don't
have this kind of energy
off the screen or it with anyone
what is what is life fun what is
enjoyment danny unchained
danny rocking a pack that we call a
fanny
in the states anyway and cool blammy
he's unchained funny
and he's got piss stains yeah on his
brains
reboot warriors of virtue
the thing with reboots this is the
problem that we run into with like we
everyone wants to reboot popular
intellectual properties but then
when we come across one that we don't
know like those are the ones that should
be rebooted because they weren't
that popular they should be the ones
that had potential and didn't hit it
um they should oh wait a minute warriors
of first oh that sounds cool
this does sound kind of cool a martial
arts fantasy
film directed by ronnie you in his
american english
language all right warriors of virtue
i'm always down for more martial i mean
if you you could you could actually
remake
some martial arts classics i think
that'd be fun and
because you could bring back actually
action sequences have really gotten a
lot crazier
so you could really uh you could
actually update some uh some movies from
the past
yeah drunken master called [ __ ] up
master remake all those bruce lee hong
kong movies with the guy from once upon
a time in hollywood
yeah you just do all of them mike moe's
on the rise yeah man just [ __ ] dude
that'd be great
i think we gotta call hollywood that's
all there is that's great
oh chad remake chud yes we would love we
would love a chad remake
yeah we we've already got effects ready
for that
we'd love it all right where are we here
we are on uh how far behind where are we
okay oh oh we're gonna do this yeah
we're gonna do this john we got this we
got this
we're gonna do this we got deflated
brady deflated brady
loves our rhymes they remind him of slim
shady
his favorite female character from the
comics is gwen
stacy lately i feel like
i'm gonna be a daisy shouts out to rosie
beatty
he's saying i agree incredibles but
emphasis on the edibles
yes what does that mean the incredibles
are high
yeah so make it like a stoner comedy
take on the incredibles
yeah that'd be great dave chappelle and
uh
you know seth rogen yeah and
uh anna ferris and
um
i'm trying to see someone who's not
james franco
uh woody harrelson there you go
okay that was great thank you i
appreciate
your support oh yeah
deflated brady i like the idea danny
says danny sorry i deleted you on the
facebook you're being kind of a dick but
i forgive you
what what's up anissa say it while we
keep going
all right what's up anissa all right
elise is back here push 2009 i only want
chris evans from the old cast
but but you gotta keep mel gibson on as
producer
of course you do otherwise how will the
film get made
a lot of people don't realize that mel
gibson produced that movie but yeah i
would i would
i wouldn't mind a push reboot or a
follow-up movie
yeah i think what you're asking for is a
follow-up anisa a push sequel
push harder push
pusher pushing more push
more push pushed pushed yeah
pushed pushed again it would be the
third one
keep pushing push once more
push five pulling
everybody push everybody push
this is great the ensemble just keeps
growing how good is ananies come on
and chris evans will just stay with the
franchise forever
all right oh what's this beautiful bliss
what do you think
of iron giant live action
on board with conditions or completely
off the table
yeah i'm the latter where are you at
iron giant live
action um john i think you would have
more of a say in this than i would i
wouldn't mind but i
john it's kind of it's kind of a
religious experience for john so i don't
know if
john would want a live-action uh iron
giant
so you speak since you're more
passionate about it i guess
i he i guess since we came up with this
[ __ ]
topic yes um i would lean
towards off the table but i would still
be curious to hear like i don't know if
brad bird really wanted to do something
like that and if it was
right the thing is i don't want to say
no but it would have to be like
the the best circumstances because that
yeah that movie i don't really think
requires it needs it
it would only go hey can we do this
live and yeah and the answer is yes
they've done various 50s period pieces
and we've seen giant robots before so
it's possible
um but it would need to have a layer
of of heart or or character quality that
the original one doesn't have or
something i don't know
i agree i think it's it's a it's a very
iffy prospect on my plate
can they do it maybe should they do it
only with disney
i love all the fake push titles you guys
are putting in the chat right now those
are great
keep pushing push push but thank you
beautiful bliss that's a great question
danny unchained with a double audio
daily double
john carter danny unchained john carter
remake
yeah you may call it of mars
yes that is it and then sell them in a
tube
dvd set so that's the full title
uh yeah i mean that's a that john carter
of mars
is a classic novel and so i feel like
that especially
also opens up the legitimacy of a push
for that especially because you know the
movie
i get the sense i've heard tell that the
movie isn't great
but isn't as bad as its performance
would indicate so yeah
i think actually if you did a john
carter remake and maybe honed in on the
literary
side so that people understand it's a
source material and not just like
i know a guy named john carter but
what's this movie you know
uh so that's where i stand john you got
the best answers
thanks man you got the best answers i
just i sit here all day and think of
them
and hope that people ask about these
specific moves but they should also do a
push
eight where they should do push
nine months later oh and it's just chris
evans this girl is giving birth
and the whole movie is just him going
push push keep pushing
and he's saying all the titles of the
previous eight push movies
everybody push everybody punch push the
baby back in we got
first we wanted it to come out now we
gotta get it back in
oh yes i'm i'm i don't know what these
comments are that you guys are making in
the chat it are bizarre i'm gonna have
to go to that point in the live stream
where everyone says weird [ __ ] i have to
go back and re-watch the push trailers
to
rejigger my memory anissa great anissa
thank you so much you keep you keep
showing the love here in the super chat
and i i'll never
i'll never i'll never forgive you on
that forgive you for that
it was for showing me compassion greg
you wanna fight
talking messing on my name i don't want
to fight you and issa i
lose you oh me you'd hold me down be
like i'm gonna piss on you
then you whip out your dick and piss on
me like oh my god it's a detachable
penis
she's a woman and she doesn't have an
actual penis oh yeah they make those
funnel things and then she's also seen
shot i wish my hair was as beautiful as
yours your hair is more beautiful than
you guys
what are you talking about you got like
color dynamics in your hair right now
where mine's just
brown you know yours has like a cool
range
it gets lighter in certain places and
it's got waves and it's like
more sexy hair and he's also talking
real dirty in the chat i don't know what
the [ __ ] yeah what's going on he's
letting out some social urges in this
live stream
what the [ __ ] is going on here isn't an
adult
friend finder okay uh but thank you
anisa
i think they should make an okay iconic
reactions
what do you do on your channel um
reviews
cooking show iconic
is certainly has these reactions that
are further
for this thing from demonic and we
should hook it up with our editor
the nerd chronic if you've got
indigestion get a colonic
oh very good john thanks i think they
should make another hancock movie as
well as jumper
starring hayden christensen that was a
really underrated movie
jumper continues on youtube
doesn't it isn't that the one that doug
lyman like totally made out of a youtube
show out of
or was trying to make a youtube show out
of i don't there's a there's a show
based on jumper
i feel like this is true but it doesn't
have hayden christensen
so there you go i mean i i think jumper
is a very underrated movie i think
i'm so surprised they haven't made a
hancock sequel that movie was such a
big hit wasn't it it was like a huge
movie
people still people know john it was a
big hit it got mixed reviews but it did
well
don't i don't know i'm giving me the
attitude as if
i'm not all right i'm saying i'm sitting
here going oh
maybe that maybe transformers
was a big hit you would be like it did
well
because you're factoring the reviews
transfers was a big hit but you wouldn't
be like it did well
no no hancock was a huge i wasn't aware
of hancock doing well at the box
it was a huge movie look at this [ __ ]
it made 629 million dollars worldwide
okay fine all right i'm
i don't doubt you oh thank god john i'm
so glad i got that out of my system
i think they should reboot hancock with
the original cast
they should do his follow-up and jumper
i don't know i think you could remake
jumper i thought it was fun and i
personally think it's a little
underrated but i wouldn't mind a remake
they wanted to do a trilogy they had a
trilogy in mind
haley i'm not sorry what's up to my
friend haley in the chat i'm not trying
to say hancock isn't good
i mean you're ruining friendships
godfather three wasn't that bad i just
think it's not that bad
um all right so we got here deontay
deonte what can i say to a day that
makes me feel so gay
you and i should take a lay deon
da yup reboot ferris bueller but it's
about his kid who's a bookworm
okay what's the plot here deontay he
just can't get his kid to skip
his kid's just like gotta get to school
you know what i do when i was your age i
skipped school
oh you know it should be fair as bueller
pulls his kid out of school yeah
and then but it's just simple let's get
out of school that's it's not a footstep
he's not ditching the kid has to come of
age but then ferris bueller also has to
realize like the adult
he he'll probably have to realize the
like adult side of like oh this is why i
shouldn't have done this when i was a
kid but his kid
like maybe he finds out that in doing
this he's being a bad influence on his
kid
or it should just be a ferris bueller's
still in high school
he's been held back for so long yeah or
or he's just at work and he decides to
you know do the same thing
or he works at the school now yeah
same movie he's just on the faculty
uh joey middleton i saw
joey rhyme him john rhyme him oh
okay um snowy
snowy joey there are kicky wafts joey
it's snowy and i'm acting a little
browy but that's only because
you're so not homely
your your you're beautiful
middleton don't uh
when you get a physical then you're
gonna have to piddle in a cup
so they can test your urine samples joey
middleton
they need to reboot aragon and do it the
right way the first one was a
disappointment
were you here when i called that out
yeah two hours ago
john was loving aragorn that was for you
yes an aragorn remake
were you there with me when i helped
decide as part of a focus group for the
trailers for aragorn were you there
i oh no no this is way before youtube
yeah
i was in a room with like it was it was
like a [ __ ]
it was like one of those things you'd
seen a movie for aragorn
screening i wasn't there no this was
like it was during the day
and then it was all the [ __ ]
producers and [ __ ] and they were all
like
like behind some glasswares like a
[ __ ] this was like an
actual like there's an actual focus
group this is a real focus group not
like a test screening
so there was a me and a bunch of kids my
age
right we're all like 16 years old we all
got paid like a hundred bucks
to give our opinion on three different
trailers on what should be the first
trailer for aragorn that we just got
pulled off of like some random
thing and we all got paid and i
disagreed with everyone
and i said i'm gonna prove you all wrong
i'm gonna start a trailer reaction
channel you'll see i'll be right here
than any of you
oh goodness gracious me
um okay sorry thanks joey i agree with
you i saw another good one in the chat
and i got distracted chris
701 christian this is bitchin thank you
for this uh commission
he just gave us a super chat without
even asking for anything
how selfless of you i would never give a
super
chat without asking a question
everything is a transaction
everything should have a trade
but thank you christian repair means a
lot chase gardner
we rhymed you firefly tv series reboot
or
another oh my god how did we fall behind
john
talking forever about the iron giant
that's that's what it was i know
they should have just left it be it
ready player one where
where is he you you missed it oh sorry
firefly tv series
reboot or another movie um i think
they're in store for another movie but
they should give it some time for joss
whedon's reputation to turn around
because that's the weird thing about
firefly is
joss whedon is kind of in a weird
spotlight right now right
yeah but you also can't do another
firefly without john
did anybody in the chat if you did or if
you know anybody who did sound off did
anybody tune in for that live joss
whedon
zoom call it i think i think it was
canceled was it cancelled he he stopped
by
on nathan fillion's one though okay he
interrupted that one but i
i don't think i think it was actually
canceled yeah okay
that seems like a good move christian
oh christian rivera did have a follow-up
all right chronicle two
sequels for nightmare and friday the
13th
um okay wait a minute so chronicle two
is something i know they've wanted to do
for a long time and i feel like that'd
be a great way to get josh
career back on track it's the only way
and also max landis he needs it
hashtag something like nope
um so yeah they have uh they have
uh they have that one but when you're
saying nightmare on elm street in front
of the 13 sequels are you talking about
sequel
like more sequels to the original
franchise or sequels to the newest
edition of nightmare on elm street and
friday the 13th
honestly if we're talking this i
wouldn't mind
rebooting nightmare again and not
completely not caring why you do it
and i would love another friday sequel
yeah i think of a proper
sequel to the one that came out that one
wasn't poorly received was it
um by purists yes i mean
are you purists well when it came out
yeah i mean there were a lot of people
who were like ah this
sucks shitty but i think especially if
you look back at it as it's aged it's
not the worst of the sequels
so like i think it's it's pretty decent
yeah fair enough and like that movie is
fun and uh there's enough there that you
could build out of it we haven't had
jason in the snow yet
erica is in the hot tub listening to
this live stream thanks erica
no don't be sorry yo i mean enjoy
yourself don't let us ruin your hot tub
also john talk to me in your southern
accent ah
i do declare i have talked i didn't say
i wasn't telling you to talk to me and
lisa's
chat is saying talk to me john if you
guys haven't heard john southern accent
it's great
it's your job terrific i do declare uh
anissa i appreciate your love in the
chat and uh another movie i saw
called out was the great cinematic
achievement known as clue
and i fee i do very much feel as though
clue
ought to be rebooted
very good mint julep you're the best
thanks you're the better half
i do my best of everything eft
eric horseman stop remaking reboots and
come up with original content
except for a complete reboot of the usa
credit to rizzo gaming
do we need to reboot the usa no let's
just make a new country
let's make a brand new country a new
country let's split the usa up into a
few countries
millennials something about millennials
millennia yeah it'll be the dance studio
that would be fun yeah we can uh
balkanize the united states and there
you go
uh yeah okay we're not gonna stop
remakes and reboots
what this should have been instead of a
live stream is one video that's ten
seconds long
just caught the title remake and reboots
you won
and then the end of the video it's just
don't remake it don't want
it end video yeah subscribe click that
notification bell
hey guys thanks for being here the watch
time is tremendous
on this on a 99 watch time on this video
but i heard a bunch of dislikes
more dislikes
oh thank you eric uh you know i'm sure
somebody out there shares your feelings
there kartik sharma's back
thank you so much wish dundee
2018 trailers were real ah yeah that
looked like a good
prospect and not australian tourism
commercials
hemsworth bros hugh jackman russell
crowe ruby rose
yeah those are all the people in that
fake trailer that would have been
a great movie i'm surprised that that
didn't actually come true yeah i
remember
actually being a bit let down when i
found out that it was just an
ad campaign i felt betrayed yeah that
happens quite a lot these days
people are there advertising speaking of
you get a ridge wallet ooh
yeah i thought they were actually making
a love actually too
whoa weren't they talking about it for a
second it was the amaze commercial thing
[ __ ] charities making fake sequel
trailers
and [ __ ] charities that's how
they get you to do good things out there
with charities
that's what it takes
[Music]
helping out people with clicking on the
hearts of the
countless individuals
oh that's right dodgeball as well oh
um anisa are we friends
i have been friend zoned lol she must be
talking to you
are you friend zone are you not
interested in a niece anymore no we're
in love we're married
we're married right now we just have a
long distance uh relationship
not napking right in the chat right now
and i'll screenshot it
what i'm just talking a napkin okay yeah
we have a long distance plate tonic
relationship don't you when we're in
love ever friend zone anissa i shan't
don't you ever friends own a niece
you we are even when she friend zones
you you better become an obsessive
stalker towards anita that's my plan i'm
already working on it
i i did you buy the radio do you buy the
jukebox to hold out her window
yes did you buy that they're a lot
smaller now it's not as impressive when
it's just
bluetooth or something and she's also
saying everyone is freaking out but
thanks for the super chat denise
everyone was freaking out about me
saying push me up against the wall i was
just adding to the push title
sorry i was too r-rated i mean if you're
gonna [ __ ] say that or not
on the internet you're setting yourself
up yeah you're gonna have to clarify
that you're going to have to clarify
that
you you kind of put yourself into this
predicament and i'm sorry you did
but push you up against the wall it
sounds like a great push
push 10. i wouldn't mind that yeah
push me down i'm an emotion eric
horseman
can't friend zone anissa not allowed big
heart
fan and greg what how to read that
discord family great
you're not friend zoned either got to
talk to this guy on instagram
beautiful face beautiful face beautiful
face beautiful voice
beautiful left bicep oh my god we don't
need to keep
talking about the tattoo the real
rejects tattoo the one and only man i
have a real rejects tattoo
one i'll never get cause when did this
channel might get me canceled oh yeah so
why would i want a tattoo to remind me
of those days
well we we did do that king of staten
island thing so eventually we'll have a
temporary tattoo
uh it's true king's sound the best movie
ever the best movie we have our best
fake tattoo ever
uh the brendan v hey buddy brendon v in
the chat
oh my god we've caught up that's what
i'm talking about yeah
reboot nick arcade i am
not familiar with this but i know you're
into musicals so i'm gonna riff on this
by saying
reboot the movie rent because that was a
boring musical and i think you can make
that better
damn shots fired at the rent shots fired
their [ __ ] rent
movie version that everyone loves i
don't know what nick arcade nickelodeon
arcade american children's game
show i i very vaguely remember oh my god
nick cannon could use this show
let's give nick cannon this show there
you go nick's arc
can be called nick's arcade too because
it'll belong to nick
cannon oh that's great nickelodeon
and then he's literally just thought of
this dead silence reboot
sequel just a thought a dead silence
reboot
i would be down so what's funny is if
you did a dead silent sequel or a reboot
they'd both be repetitive that's the
funny thing about yeah
you would because i mean where else can
you go
that's not kind of that idea very true
but uh
at the same time i i i i'd be down
um thank you so much brandon v i hope
you're feeling well buddy hayley don't
lie everyone loved the
everyone loved the rent movie dude nat
king a napkin
you sent a super chat and i really
appreciate nap king because you make me
grow
wings and i really want to sing to you
nat
king but i don't see that you made a
comment in the live stream so that way i
could have it
one of the dap kings uh okay
well i'll i'll wait for your comment
napkin um
but i appreciate you contributing super
chat anissa's saying i love you guys you
make my heart smile
we love you anissa you make her hurt
smile i smile
you ain't my butthole clenched girl
yeah and tingle that's a term
this is the kind of love that you can
receive when you don't get friends this
is called
lower your expectations on the love on
our end
thank you guys for all the super chats
we are no longer accepting
super chats we are no longer accepting
super chats
return to your vessels the very end here
we're going to the last one in fact i
think on the stream labs
no we're not we're way behind
that's right good job we got three to do
here oh we are
oh i'm sorry see i got i got fooled by
chronicle two
that's why you're [ __ ] you dumb
[ __ ] pretty dumb
yeah stupid steve it is
box has dick in a box
that's just that box again dewey
cox yeah roblox are fun to play with um
okay what's it saying remake treasure
planet we talked about this and atlantis
we talked about this
but live action that we haven't talked
about that would work
disney get on it also remake of the
craft and the oh my god yes
we make the league of extraordinary
gentlemen great call
you gotta remake the league of
extraordinary gentlemen and you know who
would really appreciate that
alan moore allen he wants more
adaptations of it he wants
more more adaptations yeah he you dude
reboot
league of extraordinary gentlemen and
from hell back to back oh
[ __ ] yeah yeah adapt whatever else we
haven't done if this cause that's what
he's
he's like why hasn't this been adapted
oh i watch all of them
i i'm very down but i appreciate that
tongue punch fart box
and i think the craft is in progress
being rebooted as we speak
so uh hell yeah though to the craft oh
hell's yeah uh
za zavlone zavlone
throw me a bone as i reach into this ice
cream scone and i atone for the fact
that my bill on my phone
is so large that it makes me want to
phone home
zolone what do you say john he said
chronicle too
and sequels or good reboots of nightmare
on elm street and friday the 13th as we
can get freddie versus jason versus ash
film we deserve
did we just get this in this in the
super chats that's why i got confused
you see we have the youtube chat and
then we got the super chats then we got
the stream labs yeah
so uh and then we have uh our our our
bank accounts
uh which are just wired right into the
stream yeah
and then we have a swiss bank account
that
you know those are only for the top tier
contributions that's right just goes
directly into our offshore bank account
for which we spend on
various illegal activities
being a top patron means you're enabling
us to do a lot so we probably
shouldn't but i feel like we comment on
this but we rhyme the [ __ ] out of your
name
not today max landis yeah uh in freddie
versus jason versus
i mean like yeah if we could get that
that's something we've been opting for
forever fun that would be fun
the way i pretty versus jason versus mia
i'll take it the way how some people are
like sick of being asked about would you
like more marvel or dc
that's how we are we're getting with
freddie versus like yes
yes agreed ryan chandler hmm
ryan ryan brian ryan
never be crying he's the man handler for
the chandler
yo rejects
my favorite dudes looking good
my friends i wanna last my god another
one
yup why does everyone want a last
starfighter remake
because this is a movie people love from
their youth man it's called
starfighter it would feature alien kids
from many worlds who play the
starfighter game and get recruited
including a girl from earth expand that
you know that would be cool
he is one of the few people to say i
want a remake of something and having an
actual clear cut here's my idea of what
to do
like a very specific take on what to do
then i'm all for it that's a great great
idea
now here's the thing i haven't seen the
last starfighter so i can't really
comment on it
but you know what this stream has the
amount of people saying remake the last
star fighter has made me go i gotta
[ __ ] watch this
last starfighter movie yeah then call up
jason dolan and talk about it
i appreciate this i appreciate this
confirm this is the last of the stream
labs for today let's confirm
it and let's confirm off screen so the
up oh
brendan v has one more in the super chat
denise you missed denise
johnson see i have to hold the fort down
see oh okay yeah well they're the same
length and they both end in a smile
so i got confused and this is insane
last one i promise i love you i'll see
you all soon
we love the [ __ ] out of you anissa you
make
john poop when he is feeling constipated
that's love for you you opened me up and
the brendan v he's saying thanks
stds i'm doing okay by the way
hated the red movie thanks stunts
where the heck is the wicked movie i
know
great call man where is that wicked
movie aren't they they're
probably stalled out but they're working
on it right they should make a lion an
annotation of the musical
of the lion king musical yeah yeah do it
with actual actors
in those stage apparatus why hasn't
disney plus tried
filming the lion king and putting that
on that
that would be terrific is there i mean
is there a
recorded version of the stage show
because if there is i shouldn't
record the entire time no one recorded
it
always do an official recording of like
whatever
you know sometimes they'll do a concert
recording that's like not as well staged
or something i don't know koran
i will be last where's that body rot
this is rebooting thank you anisa you
are the last jedi thank you anisa
yes reboot dick tracy home alone
crossover small soldiers i like that
idea
keep it for the next time we do
crossover let's reboot the lone ranger i
agree
that's true all stories are reboots in
some way all right guys
thank you so much this was a really fun
live stream
we usually like to end when we're
feeling like we're gonna die
yeah yeah today we'll end on a high dose
it's our first two hour livestream
stargate i appreciate yes
um that would be a great one uh yeah i
have to do
i have to start editing for umbrella
academy because um i gotta film for
umbrella academy tomorrow
so i'm trying to get ahead on that
because it's also elizabeth crazy's
birthday and i want to stop by my
neighbors at some point and
got to finish up a couple of other
videos he has to film for patreon
uh right now for tv show reaction what's
up
sorry richard bentley brought up rubber
and i just i agree with you yes
sequel to the killer tire movie um and
yeah gonna shoot for patreon
keep keep a lookout for demon slayer
episode 10 on monday
go join our discord after party over
there yeah
thank you to everyone who contributed
during this stream this was a fun one
this was we gotta i'm gonna have to
bring this theme back
michael b omnimedia follow him on
youtube
[ __ ] i'm sorry i didn't finish
doom patrol on time i'm only on episode
three at the moment
i love everyone who participated here
hit the like button
tm no you're too sweet we do it all for
you
and for me and for john from my
girlfriend
and i'm hungry i'm hungry too
let's take a [ __ ] let's empty out even
more
we'll see you guys soon thank you wacky
as [ __ ] i had a great we had a great
time
you'd be safe this weekend um yeah
love y'all peace much love
re reboot this live stream oh whoa thank
god this stream's done right
oh my god jesus that was just exhausting
all these people who i don't like
talking to everyone
i just hate them so mean so glad this
stream is talking
pitching these ideas i gotta act like i
enjoy
being here and why am i still even
talking about my people
why am i still talking about why am i
still also talking about talking to this
mic there's no point
man [ __ ]
i'm just kidding i'll see you guys soon
this is brought to you by sarcasm that's
called
love you guys see you soon peace